pat 40 covers college football and uh
college athletics for sports illustrated
and uh
he's joining us on the program here uh
where do you want to start with this pat
because it feels like you're always the
bearer of bad news
so do you have any good news for college
football fans
uh let's see the uh the pac-12 will
announce a schedule today
uh as has obviously the the acc and scc
of allow
scheduling models so we're gonna lease
schedule games i'm not saying we're
going to play them
dan but we are going to schedule them
okay that gives people something to talk
what's the pac 12 schedule going to be
it'll be 10 games it'll be conference
only uh you know they're adding one
league game per team so that everybody's
playing an even five home five road
uh i'm not sure start dates yet but
that's that's been a really interesting
thing and i heard you allude to it
before the break there about
where some conferences are looking like
hey let's go early
others are like no no let's push it back
and go late
that's to the point that i don't think
anybody knows what's the right thing to
do here
and i don't think we're going to have a
bowl season i i'm starting to look at
the time frame if you're going to play
like the sec conference
title game is what december 19th here
um do you think we're gonna have bowl
game a bull season
i think if we have a season we'll have
bowl games yeah if they can get to the
end of the season i think we will
they'll push them back they'll schedule
them wherever and whenever
as you know the worldwide leader will
we'll we'll find places to put vulgate
uh that it's funny yet because december
19th normally that would be the weekend
when they would start with like five
bowl games now that's going to probably
be a conference championship
weekend you know they'll stash the
camellia bowl
on mid-january if they need to if they
think it'll work
you uh mentioned that the acc had a
preemptive strike where
they were not going to be the bad guy in
these rivalry games that they have with
the sec at the end of the season where
it's florida florida state it's clemson
south carolina
uh georgia tech georgia so explain what
the acc did
and then what the sec then tried to
counter
yeah it was a lovely bit of skullduggery
and this just goes to show these power
five
programs that i think we use the analogy
the five crime families that's what they
are you know they kind of
kind of get along but when it comes down
to rubber hitting road they're all in it
for themselves so
at 3 30 on wednesday word starts getting
out that the acc
or the sec i'm sorry has finalized its
schedule that they only want to play
conference games
at about four o'clock 4 20 the acc
suddenly puts out a blast to its members
we are releasing our schedule
they weren't going to do it that day
they had agreed on it earlier in the day
but they were not going to release it
but they wanted to get it out ahead of
the stc news
and then make it and portray the
schedule and show hey we have this open
date
for a non-conference game played in our
home state
which obviously is for those games to
accommodate those games
they wanted to put that out there and
paint the sec into the corner as the
ones that are saying no no
we're not going to play florida florida
state we're not going to play georgia
georgia tech
clemson south carolina has played every
year since 1913. no we're not going to
do it louisville kentucky
etc so i was a quite a deaf little
maneuver by the acc
notre dame in the acc is this a
a a temporary relationship
i think it is uh you know i'm sure hey
they the acc will continue to leave the
porch slide on
for that wandering bachelor that is uh
notre dame they go they're going to get
them they're going to share towels
they're going to share
uh dishes and they're going to share a
bank account for one year
but i think it will not last being on
that i think that notre dame so
cherishes its independence its
ability to schedule nationally and
recruit nationally
that it will say thank you very much uh
but now we are going back to our
bachelor pad
i'm getting more concerned about the big
ten if the big ten has football
what do you think yeah legitimate
concern i mean
they put out a memo to the league
members yesterday
and the first paragraph says we're still
not sure we're gonna play
uh that's the baseline starting point
right there
they said if protocols are in place and
things are going well
next week we will probably go ahead and
green light starting camp
those are that's if and then after that
we'll see how it goes and we'll maybe
release a schedule next week it could
leak out earlier but i would think that
will be next week as well
uh they are they've been very cautious
about this going forward i mean you look
at
rutgers in the situation there in new
jersey not even sure whether people can
travel
into or out of the state to play them
there's travel restrictions
in ohio there's travel restrictions in
pennsylvania uh there's problems all
over the place that i think
they are certainly more wary of or
willing to acknowledge than the other
conferences are
what did you think of my idea of maybe
moving the season
up and then having the ability to have
bye weeks where you could almost hit a
reset button for these
these colleges these students yeah i
mean you know that's there's two
competing schools of thought there's
that which the big 12 looks like they're
going to do i mean they're pushing up
games to august 29th
uh versus the sec going to september
26th and the sec's reasoning is
we're going to bring everybody back to
campus in mid-august all the students
and the virus is just going to blow up
and we're going to have to shut things
down for a couple weeks
so let's delay our start but if the
delay you start you also push further
into
flu season traditional flu season and
what people think will be traditional
covent season eventually
uh so i would think really if you feel
like you can start
early start early and then you just hang
on through whatever's going to happen
you know i i agree with you when it
comes to you know
all these the power five conferences it
felt like hey we're in it together let's
try to figure this out like what are you
guys doing and what are you guys doing
all of a sudden the acc
it it's that game i don't know if it was
world of warcraft or
when uh leroy jenkins where the guy is
talking about
you know they have strategy and all of a
sudden the guy yells out leroy jenkins
like he's going all in
to ruin their strategy that's what it
felt like the acc was like
lee roy jenkins we're going all in
oh yeah yeah it's like my name's called
i'm going no
i mean truly and that's you know the big
ten's the one that shanked everybody to
begin with
together they're like now we're just
gonna announce our schedule we're not
even gonna tell anybody else
then the pac-12 is like oh i guess we
better too then the other three were all
oh now we're in it together and then the
acc pulls the
stunt with the sec so everybody's mad at
everybody nobody trusts anybody
it's college sports if you had to bet a
week's pay
will the big ten play football this fall
i'm gonna say yes uh i'm not sure
everybody will but i think that the
intention is there and i think that
they will start what do you mean
everybody every school in the big ten
right i'm not you know i mean again like
rutgers let's wait and see what happens
there now they've got they've gotten
their testing numbers
under control but again travel situation
there
is going to be difficult you know i
think there are people within the big
ten that would like to play in the
spring
uh and they may say we can't play now
but i think the majority will want to
play in the fall and we'll try to play
in the fall
my problem with the springtime football
is you're going to be
playing two football seasons in a span
of nine months
and you're going to have some marquee
players who are just going to say
no i'm not going to do it that close to
the combine and that close to the draft
and
i just can't see how you're going to
cram that in and then
you know five or six months later you're
going to start the season again a new
season
yeah remember way back a long time ago
when like concussions were an issue when
people were worried about that you're
going to play
you're going to try to play a schedule
in the spring and then turn around and
get everybody
through that and then back into contact
again a couple of months
maybe later and have another season i i
i agree that that's problematic and
and yeah players opting out play you
know we're going to see some already we
did saw the virginia tech cornerback opt
out and i think we're going to see more
of that you push it to the spring i
think you will see dozens and dozens of
players out there i think your next
column
you got to lead with something positive
do your best
and i'm not talking about positive tests
i'm talking about something positive pat
okay i'll i'll do my best i'll i'll see
what i can come up with
i've been encouraged to do to be more
positive and less realistic
oh i get that every day on the show yeah
stop being realistic be positive i'm
like um
okay uh great to talk to you thanks
again pat
thank you that's a pat 40 sports
illustrated uh senior writer